- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest is Professor
Gananath Obeyesekere,
who is professor of anthropology
emeritus at Princeton University.
One of the world's
leading anthropologists,
he is visiting the campus
as the Foerster Lecturer
for the year 2003.
He is the author, most recently,
of Imagining Karma, published by UC Press.
Professor, welcome to Berkeley.
- Glad to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well I born in Sri Lanka
and also raised there.
That's where I had my early education
and my university education,
at least for my BA.
- And looking back, how do you think
your parents shaped your
thinking about the world?
- Well, my father was a kind of,
for that time, a kind
of cosmopolitan figure.
I mean, he was born in a small village
in the south of Sri Lanka, as I was too,
and as a young man he went to India
and he studied both Ayurvedic
and Western medicine,
but got his degree in classical Ayurveda,
that is, Indian medicine.
And then he came back to Sri
Lanka and he taught there.
So actually, he was fluent in about
three or four languages,
including English,
and we had a sense of a kind of
a broad education as
a consequence of that.
- So you were exposed to many cultures,
in a way, very early.
- Well, in a sense I was
exposed to many cultures,
because I spanned the whole
colonial era, to some degree.
I mean I was born in the colonial period
and I lived through the
period of independence
and freedom and so forth.
So in that sense I was exposed to
the colonial epoch, so to speak.
And since my father knew English
and Sanskrit and Hindi
and Sinhala and so forth,
I was exposed to a wide range
of languages, I would say.
My father was interested in
Sanskrit or Indian medicine,
and for that matter I have written
some articles on it too,
so there is continuity, one might say.
- And how old were you at the time
of the struggle for independence?
- Well, Sri Lanka was in a
fortunate situation where,
maybe it was an unfortunate one,
we didn't have to actually
struggle for independence.
The Indians did all the struggling
and we sort of had it
on a plate, you know.
So this was, I might
have been, I don't know,
15 or so when that happened.
- Was there an effect on you?
Or did it just, the world
changed just one day.
- Not at all.
I mean, it did have an effect on me.
During the war years, for example,
this was, we got
independence after the war,
and during the war years, my education
was disrupted, you
might say, in one sense,
or enhanced if you want to
say it in another sense.
Because we had to move from
school to school and so forth.
And that, looking back on it, you know,
I found that a good experience.
It was sort of a broadening of my mind
going from one place to another.
- And was this all in your home country?
- It's in my home country, yeah.
- So you did what we could call
the undergraduate education in Sri Lanka.
Is that when you got interested
in anthropology, or was it later?
- Well actually, I mean if I
could switch back a little bit,
I was a terrible high school student.
And I always tell my children,
all you learn in high school you can
pick it up in six months later on.
But fortunately, I
managed to get through my,
one might say scraped through
my university entrance exam.
But when I went into the university,
I think, that was a wonderful experience.
And I moved into English literature.
That was my major, you see.
So this was a period in
European intellectual thought
where there was a
certain amount of ferment
with the new criticism coming in,
you know, in England in
Cambridge and Oxford.
In Cambridge in particular,
you had a great literary
critic, F.R. Leavis, you see.
And our teachers were
students of F.R. Leavis,
so we were sort of, one might say,
educated in, at that
time, the most powerful
sort of literary critical
movement of the time.
And it was through my literary education,
and though we called it English literature
we read a heck of a lot
of European literature,
Ibsen, French literature, and so forth,
so it was broadly compiled, one might say.
But this was a time, after all, people,
Eliot was writing The Waste Land
and people were talking on mythmaking.
You know, even in my lecture yesterday
I was talking of Yeats, who was,
in some sense, a great mythmaker.
So I think I got very
interested in anthropology
through this bizarre source,
through literature, through Frazer.
Because remember, Eliot used
Frazer and Weston and so forth,
people we hardly read nowadays,
but that's the way I got
interested in anthropology.
And also through collections.
This was a period in which
people were collecting
Scottish ballads, you know, and so forth.
So I was infected with this kind of
early romanticism, one might say.
So during weekends, what I did was
I used to take a train
ride into a distant place,
get off the train, wander
into villages and so forth,
go into a Buddhist temple,
stay the night there,
chat with people, and I
used to collect folk songs.
You see?
And still could rattle
off hundreds and hundreds
of Sri Lankan Sinhalese folk songs.
But that gradually drew
me into village life.
So very early, as an undergraduate,
several of us started a journal
which was called Sanskruti, in Sinhala.
And Sanskruti means a culture.
So you can see, culture in
a sort of Arnoldian sense,
or T.S. Eliot sense of culture, you know?
But that sense of culture, in some sense,
drew me into anthropology,
particularly the village experience,
collecting folk material.
And also a kind of romantic
looking back at my own past,
because I was born in a village,
at age four we went to
the city of Colombo,
the only big city, then as well as now,
and went into sort of private
schools, what you might call.
So in some sense I was trying
to look back into my past.
And I would say that, in a sense,
virtually everything I wrote
is in some sense a
reflection of Sri Lanka.
My own past, my own history,
as well as the history of the nation.
Even when I'm writing something,
let us say, on Captain Cook.
- And what would you describe as your
intellectual and emotional stance
toward what you were doing?
Was the motivation to preserve?
To understand the complexity?
Or these things and more.
- In my early forays?
- Yeah, yeah.
- In my early forays, it was,
I'm ashamed to confess,
it was almost antiquarian.
I mean, it's a horrible term to use,
but in a sense I was trying
to collect these things
because you're first,
you were first confronted
with the impact of modernity
in the country, after all.
And we felt that something
is going to get lost.
And I presume that's the same motivation
that let Alfred Lord and
other collectors, you know,
to deal with European ballads
and epics and so forth.
That was the spur that
led me in my early years.
- And then your graduate
education was where?
- Well, when I graduated from
the University of Sri Lanka,
one of my professors, who
was really a student of,
as I pointed out, of F.R. Leavis,
he said, why don't you join
the English department,
which was probably the most
prestigious department,
you know, given the colonial period.
And I refused.
And he sort of said,
that's nice, you know,
you're one of the first people
who refused this kind of thing.
And I got a, I applied, I
got several scholarships.
I mean I could have gone
to London or to Oxford,
because I headed the list
of graduating students,
so I had automatic scholarships
to go to London or Oxford.
But I had a sneaking
sort of anticolonialism,
which I still have, sneaking kind of way.
And I refused to go the way of others.
Almost everyone else, all the sort of,
you might say, the left
wing leader of Sri Lanka
all went to London or Oxford or Cambridge.
But I thought that's not my way,
and I went, I applied for a Fulbright.
Everyone was horrified.
My father was horrified.
You're going to America?
I mean, this is some
sort of terrible thing,
instead of going to Oxford or Cambridge.
So I got this Fulbright and I went.
I applied to Harvard,
Chicago, Princeton, Yale,
and I got into the University
of Washington in Seattle.
So that's how I first went there.
But in between, in between there was
a sort of liminal period, one might say,
a couple of years after I graduated
and before taking up my Fulbright.
And I had to have a project
so I started working on some
very interesting rituals,
particularly mother
goddess cults in Sri Lanka.
And since I was a Frazerian at that time,
I had no idea that one
should go to a village
and stay their for a whole year
and study the village
throughout its early cycle.
That was an anthropological
model of which I was not aware.
I was aware of the Frazerian model
where you went all over the place.
So at that time I had a
terribly old tape recorder
and a huge battery and converter,
and went from place to place
in military trucks
abandoned by the British,
and went recording these
mother goddess cults
all over the country, you know?
On reflection, I thought,
what a haul this was.
I would never have done that.
I would never have got
this massive haul of data
if I followed the conventional
anthropological model.
And I used some of the
material for my masters
and then, later on, I
used that for my work
on the cult of the goddess Pattini,
which is a kind of comparative
study of a single cult,
intensive cult all over Sri
Lanka and in South India.
- Help us understand what it takes
to be an anthropologist and do that work.
What are the talents and skills
that a student should understand
that are necessary for
being an anthropologist?
- Well, I hate to
pontificate on this issue,
because it seems to me
that different people
have different sort of
stances on this whole thing.
My own guess, coming
from my own experience,
is somewhat different from the
conventional anthropologists.
After all, the normal
anthropologist, you might say,
is someone who is either in Europe
or in France or in England,
studying another culture which he,
he was not nurtured or socialized in.
In my case, this was entirely different.
And I was studying, in
some sense, my own culture,
but through the prism of an
anthropological detachment,
one my say, which was, to
me, necessary at the time.
So I would say that it
was not all that different
from normal anthropology, in some sense,
because I was raised, I
was born in a village,
I was raised in an urban situation,
I went to schools in which the
primary language was English.
We were discouraged to speak
our own language, Sinhala,
by our English teachers.
So, going back to study villages was,
in a sense, to understand my own culture,
which is not quite the thrust
of conventional anthropology.
But on the other hand, the
villages in which I worked
were, in a sense, sort of
different from my urban lifestyle,
my urban education, my
middle class background,
the fact that, for the most
part, I spoke English at home.
- But then later, I mean, did you remain
the same kind of anthropologist
in your later work?
Or were you beyond acquiring
the professional skills,
obviously, that your
graduate education gave.
How much is changed in
the way you do your work?
- I think, I haven't reflected on this,
I have to wait 'til I
write my memoirs I guess.
- This'll be the beginning.
- To deal with this kind of thing.
But sure, certainly I've
changed quite a lot,
I assume, over the intervening years.
But in one sense, I really believe,
when we were graduate students,
we were, in a sense,
sometimes taught explicitly,
sometimes implicitly, that it won't do
to study one's own culture, you know?
I don't believe in that at all.
I mean, I think that to
study one's own culture
is not a bad idea through a
kind of anthropological lens,
with a certain amount of detachment.
And I see this coming back
in full circle right now,
where I have my own
students in Princeton now
going to study their
own cultures, you see,
in a sense, either American culture
or European culture, and so forth.
So I would say that doing anthropology
has certainly expanded my consciousness
to a certain degree, broadened my outlook.
I'm in a sense, you know, a
cosmopolitan being, in some way,
and that's due to my
anthropological education.
- And which theories and theorists
have influenced you most?
Obviously parts of Freud's work,
even criticizing it is one thing.
Who else, and tell us a little bit
about Freud's influence on you.
- Well Freud's influence was, again,
came through my literary interests.
I mean, after all, Freud was a figure
of the literary imagination, I would say,
even before he was a product
of the anthropological imagination.
People interested in literature
were also interested in Freud
as they were interested in Frazer.
I read Freud when I was an undergraduate.
I read Finnegan's Wake when
I was an undergraduate.
You know, in high school I read Ulysses.
So we had a tremendous education
in European literature.
And that included people like Freud.
Not that I understood Freud very much,
but through Freud, you know,
I began to understand something
I mentioned in my lecture last time,
that the Sri Lankan Oedipus
is like the Greek one.
So through Freud I began to understand
my own background, my own
situation in Sri Lanka.
I was a great rebel as a young man.
I used to almost never stay at home,
wander out in villages
even as a young person.
And Freud helped me to understand
my own rebellious Oedipal
kinds of feelings.
So in that sense, Freud was not
simply a kind of intellectual
mentor, one might say,
but also someone who helped me
to understand my own emotional conflicts.
One might as well state the truth of that.
And when I, in my early work, therefore,
I tried to bring Freud into the picture.
And the University of
Washington helped me a lot,
because at that time, in anthropology,
when I first went there,
there was an anthropologist,
Melville Jacobs,
who was very much interested
in the American Indians and Freud.
And Jacobs was really a
very imaginative writer
and very few people actually read him now.
And I went for classes
in the medical school
at the University of Washington,
and Gert Heilbrunn, who was
a kind of Viennese emigre,
was a Freudian, very
standard kind of Freudian,
and a charismatic kind of teacher,
so I learned a heck of a lot from him.
And after, or while, Mel Spiro,
whom I mentioned in my
class, also came in,
but that was during the latter part
of my stay in the
University of Washington,
when I was doing my PhD, you know.
Mel was a very strong influence
and encouraged me in
the Freudian direction.
And I like Freud for other reasons too.
He was a wonderful writer.
You know, as Thomas Mann
put it, he was a stylist.
Even in English translation.
- Other theorists that
emerge as important,
either in your development or later,
as people who you duel with
as you achieve stature in the field?
- Yeah, along with Freud, you see,
was my interest in Weber.
That came in much later.
And my PhD dissertation
was not at all Freudian.
Simply, I mean this was perhaps a sign
of perversity on my part, or
tactfulness, you might say,
that the dominant paradigm at that time,
when I was at the
university of Washington,
was British social anthropology.
And British social anthropology
was very anti-Freudian.
American anthropology was very
sympathetic to Freud, as you well know.
But not British anthropology.
So British anthropology was very much
interested in social structure,
the study of kinship systems and so forth.
So my first foray into
conventional anthropological
fieldwork, you know,
where you spend some time
in a particular village,
was a study of kinship and land tenure
in a remote village in Sri Lanka.
And there I brought in Max Weber.
Weber became a very powerful
influence at that time,
and later on I began to
read a lot more of Weber,
and I saw a kind of emotional affinity
to my own interests, intellectual
affinity I would say.
I mean, Freud was more emotional affinity.
And one of my interests at that time
was to use Weberian ideas of culture,
you know, as a kind of system of meanings
by which human beings
related to the world.
And also in some way a
Weberian methodology,
the notion of ideal types,
which again I resurrected
back in my most recent work.
So Weber and Freud became the sort of,
the foundations, one might say,
of the beginning of my
anthropological career,
and thus they are there to some extent,
even though I have transformed
Weber through Wittgenstein
and various other influences in my life.
- And any other theorists
that we should mention?
- Yeah, there are many other theorists
that I was interested in.
Evans-Pritchard, for example.
Because Evans-Pritchard, from a long time,
presented an idea to which
I was highly sympathetic,
namely, that anthropology
is history in some sense.
And to this day I feel
that, however much you know,
positivism has impinged on
anthropology very early.
At that time, my first book was called
Land Tenure In Village Ceylon:
a Sociological and Historical Study.
So history became a very very
crucial element in my own thinking.
And in a sense, that's natural, isn't it?
I mean after all I am a Sri Lankan,
though I am an American citizen too,
I am a Sri Lankan born and raised,
and to me, getting
interested in my own past
was very very relevant.
So through Evans-Pritchard
and other thinkers
of that same sort, I
became very much interested
in history, and that's
not alien to Weber either.
- And what I'm hearing you say is that
at the core of your work
is an interdisciplinary sensitivity,
that your work as an anthropologist
really reflects all sorts of sources
in terms of the influence of theory,
from, Weber was a sociologist obviously,
Freud was a psychologist, and so on.
And that is kind of enriching for you
as you do your anthropology.
- Yes, indeed it is.
As a matter of fact, some of my,
I would add to that and say that
right through my literary
interests are there.
In a sense, I am glad that I am
not a professor English literature.
I'd rather read literature for fun.
And to some extent, literary writing,
and I don't know, I try to write well,
and literature has been
a real passion for me,
a personal passion.
When I have my shower,
I can quote, you know,
reams and reams of poetry.
I mean I still can.
And storytelling, you know,
has become a part of my interests,
particularly my recent work
on what I call cannibal talk.
I'm very much interested in
how people invent stories,
what I call narratives of the self.
So storytelling, which after all
is something I was nurtured as a child,
you know, in Sri Lanka
everyone tells stories,
the women who brought
me up told me stories,
Buddhist stories, then
in my intellectual career
I was reading novels,
fiction, poetry, and so forth,
so storytelling too is a part
of my intellectual baggage.
- You must have been
positioned to the ways in which
Western social theory
could get things wrong
because of a lack of
empathy or understanding
with the setting where the
problem was being studied.
Tell us a little about that
and how you dealt with those tensions
and how you came to
realizations like that.
- You know, again, it's a sort of
difficult question to answer
because it permeates my
work to such a degree.
I would say it cuts both ways.
On the one hand, I am very critical
of the way sort of, you know,
European scholarship approaches the other.
You know, third world
cultures including my own.
I'm very critical of that way.
And also critical of my own culture.
I am terribly unpopular in
Sri Lanka in some sense,
at least among small groups of people,
because I am very critical
of the nationalism in the country,
the nationalism that led to this
sort of terrifying war in which
we are now implicated and fortunately
having a breathing spell right now.
So I am both critical of the
Western attitude to the other
as well as our attitude to the West
and trying to pretend that colonialism,
for example, some extreme nationalists say
colonialism has had no impact on us,
we have the same Buddhist
culture going right through.
When I try to point out,
in several of my works
including Buddhism Transformed
and in this book, you
see that in some sense
the Buddhism that we now believe in
is a colonial product, you see.
It is a product of Western theorists
and translators of Buddhists texts
who came in the 19th Century.
And I'm not saying that's
necessarily bad, you know,
but it led to a transformation of ethics,
the transformation of the way
we look at the world in Sri Lanka.
And it is foolish to deny
this colonial impact.
I am a product of that too, myself.
You know, as I sit with
you, speaking English,
trained in English literature.
And so forth, so why deny this?
At the same time, I don't want to sort of,
sort of whitewash the colonial enterprise.
In a lot of my work, the work
on Captain Cook for example,
and the work I'm now doing
on what I call cannibal talk,
is the way the European
looks at the other.
And Cannibal Talk, when it appears,
I hope it appears soon,
will deal with that issue.
So is the Cook book, you see.
- Tell us a little bit
about the Cook book.
Because I know it's
really an important work.
- Well the Cook book, in some sense,
was an attempt to be critical,
all this time I've been
critical of my own country
and the way they have framed
Buddhism and so forth.
With the Cook book, I move into a kind of
critique of the way in which
European scholarship
has looked on the other,
you know, third world people and so forth.
The Cook book really
deals with the phenomenon
of this great explorer, Captain Cook,
who then goes into, at that time,
the last part of the known world.
The rest of the world was
fairly well-known and mapped.
He goes into Polynesia.
He's a brilliant, great figure.
I don't doubt that at all, I
call him Prospero in one sense.
You know, trying to discover new world.
And one of the interesting things is,
wherever he goes, he
brings English animals.
He plants the landscape with
English trees and fruit trees.
It's a method of incorporating
this other society
within the frame of English
ideas and culture and so forth.
So I am not denying that
Cook was a very important
figure of the European Enlightenment,
and he the Prospero side to his persona,
but I am saying that's not all there is.
There's a dark side to the Enlightenment,
you see, which we know
now today, I'm afraid.
There's a dark side to the Enlightenment,
and Cook represents what I
also call the Kurtz persona,
that is, the person who
goes into this foreign land
and gets, in some sense,
corrupted, so to speak.
And I show the two aspects
of the Kurtz persona.
- Kurts from Heart of Darkness.
- Heart of Darkness.
I mean, so on the one hand,
he's bringing in the Enlightenment,
the light, in some way,
and on the other hand he's
bringing in the darkness,
because of the way he treats
the natives and so forth.
So that part of the Cook enterprise
has been smothered in the representations,
scholarly representations,
the popular representations.
So what I do is to read between the lines,
read the footnotes that others have used,
and bring that to the surface.
So when Cook, the crux of the issue
is that when Cook went to Hawaii,
the way that European scholars,
some very distinguished ones, present it
is that he was treated
as one of their gods,
the god Lono, 'cause he was called Lono.
But then I find out,
that's the title of the book,
European Mythmaking in the Pacific.
The whole thrust of the book is to show
that this is a European myth.
And myths are, after all,
not just the prerogative
of us in the third world, so to speak,
but Europe to is a great
mythmaking culture.
We know that.
Even now, as we are here,
it's myths that are being
created about wars and so forth.
So what I try to show in that
is the idea that the white
civilizer is a god to natives
is a structure of the long
running European thought.
It comes in Columbus, it comes in Cortes,
and it comes in Captain Cook.
And my argument was to show
that they did treat
Cook with great respect
on the model of one of their chiefs,
they bowed before him and so forth,
but they did that to their chiefs too.
And there is no evidence
in Cook's journals
and the journals of the
writers onboard ship
that he was deified at all.
But there is definite evidence
that soon after Cook's death,
that there were pantomimes
in Covent Garden
in which Cook was
deified by the Hawaiians.
So that was a European
construction, so to speak.
Even before the first
ships went back to Hawaii.
So my argument, therefore, is that,
not just to point out the dark side
of the Enlightenment project,
particularly in respect of
the voyages of discovery,
but also to show European
mythmaking at its peak,
where Cook is transformed
into a god for natives.
- Now, your new book is
called Imagining Karma.
It was published by UC Press.
And you spoke about it
in yesterday's lecture.
What was the problem that you
were trying to address here?
- Well I can put it in this way.
All of us intellectuals,
myself included at one time,
we imagine that theories of reincarnation,
you know, is an Indic phenomenon.
All of us think, well, you know,
we associate that with Buddhism
and with Hinduism and with
the religions of India.
And a few people, of course,
who are very well-versed in the classics,
know that Pythagoras and
so forth also had that.
But basically it's an Indic thing.
And even there are scholars who say
that Pythagoras borrowed it from India.
So, you know, in the course of my reading
and my anthropological experience,
I began to question that whole thing.
So the book was, the spur that led
to the writing of the book was
to expand the notion that the ideas
of rebirth is not an Indic phenomenon,
to decenter India, to delocalize India
as the home and ground of rebirth.
And to show that it is found,
in a recent book called
Amerindian Rebirth,
younger scholars have shown
that Northwest Coast
Indians and other Indians
had beautiful circular theories of rebirth
where the soul goes round and round
and comes back to the same
patrilineal or matrilineal group,
these beautifully circular systems.
And then we know from West Africa,
from Igbo, which I
describe in great detail.
And other West African cultures,
they too had theories of rebirth.
And the locus classicus, you know,
Malinowski, our great ancestor after all,
wrote the Trobriand Islands,
the religion of the Trobriand Islands,
and that's, again, a wonderful
system of rebirth theory.
So this led me to argue that, you know,
led to a kind of theoretical argument,
trying to make the point that,
whether you are in ancient Greece
or in ancient India or present-day India,
or whether you are dealing with
what I call small-scale societies,
nowadays it's very unfashionable
to use primitive and
tribe and all of that,
there is, in rebirth, a kind
of elementary structure.
That is, if you have a rebirth theory,
you have the soul coming from some sphere,
born into the womb of a
woman, conceived there,
one is then born in the human world,
you go around the life cycle,
you die, you enter into
another world, you come back,
and you have a cyclical
structure of continuity.
You know, it goes round and round.
It doesn't matter where you are.
It may be Plotinus, it may be Empedocles,
Pindar, Pythagoras, doesn't matter.
Or the Buddha, or the Jain
saints, or the Amerindians.
That elementary structure is there.
And any other system, so to speak,
whether you are talking
about Greek rebirth or Plato,
I think, contrary to some
of my classical friends,
I believe that Plato was not writing
his stuff on rebirth as
allegory, as many people think,
but he really believed in it, you know?
So whether you are Plato or
whether you're the Buddha,
and these are very powerful thinkers,
they have to build their system of thought
on this elementary structure.
This permits, in some sense,
comparison, I am saying.
So since this permits comparison,
I am sort of arguing against
the dominant trend in my own profession
and in postmodernism in general,
that everything in the
world is fragmented,
cultural and ethical
relativism is everywhere,
and I am saying, yes it is everywhere
but it is also not, you know?
And you take these structures
and you can demonstrate the existence
of comparability in cultures.
- So what I hear you're saying,
and again, I'm not an anthropologist,
so for the layperson, you're saying
that what you're
discovering, on the one hand,
is a kind of universalism, in
this case the rebirth story,
that appears in all sorts of places,
but on the other hand there is a richness
in the particular setting
in which this occurs.
And so the job of the analyst,
in your case the anthropologist,
is to see that, but on the other hand,
dig out the local story and the way
it's played out in that system.
- Yeah, that's part of my argument.
Part of my argument is that
on the one hand these things
are comparable, on one level,
because they share this
elementary structure.
You have to build, so to speak,
complex system of thought,
and Buddhism is a tremendously
on these structures.
Therefore, once these systems
of thought are constructed,
obviously Buddhism is
different from Greek culture,
it is different from Amerindians.
But even so, even at
the level of complexity,
there are some interconnections.
You can't avoid them.
So that is why I always say I'm both
a relativist and an
anti-relativist in some sense.
- One final question.
If you were to advise
students who wanted to do
this kind of work that you
have done in your career,
what advice would you give them
in terms of preparing for the future?
- Well, one advice that I give them
is not to be seduced by current trends.
I mean, to put it in this way,
that nowadays when I
read a PhD dissertation,
it is not, I mean, people have
to use Foucault, for example.
I mean, virtually every
dissertation I read
has something to do with Foucault.
I mean, I'm saying, I myself believe
that Foucault was a wonderful person,
a great thinker and so forth,
but I'm also saying that one
cannot be seduced to that degree.
Like me, for example,
I very much admire Foucault,
but I like to go back
into Nietzsche, you see,
whom, I mean after all, the will to power
was not Foucault's invention,
it was, in some sense,
Nietzsche's invention.
And in my way of thinking,
though Nietzsche was not
as systematic a thinker,
we all know that, as Foucault was,
but there's a damn sight more insight
in Nietzsche's thinking
about the will to power,
the creative aspect of the will to power,
the destructive aspect
of the will to power.
So I'm saying to some of, you know,
to address your problem, I would say
that one should not be
seduced by current fashion.
One should approach
current fashion critically,
and one should not dump the past entirely,
because after all, in some sense,
you know, all of us are
creatures of tradition.
And to dump the past, to dump Freud,
to dump Weber and so forth,
in my view, is a mistake.
I mean, one should adapt Freud,
one should rethink Freud,
one should rethink Weber,
bring perhaps Freud and Weber in line
with postmodernity to some degree.
But I don't think one should
be seduced by current fashions.
That's my thought on the matter.
- With that note, I
wanna thank you very much
for joining us today and for coming
to the campus to give
the Foerster Lecture.
Thank you.
- It's a pleasure to be here.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.